For a person with a metastasis to the lungs, what are some ways to best support lung function,
dealing with weasiness, sporadocophiness, slimy flim? Okay, so there's some herbs that can help
surgically. Again, I don't know anything about this person at all. Those are metastasis from the liver,
was a metastasis from the breast. Remember, whenever you have metastasis of cancer,
it's not a new primary cancer. So let's say you have breast cancer, it's metastasis to the lungs.
It's not lung cancer. It's still breast cancer cells that are in the lungs. So breast cancer,
metastasis to the liver. It's not liver cancer. It's breast cancer in the liver. So of course,
you're doing everything you can to kill the cancer. So I hope that that is a given.
But what do you do for lung function is the question. You know, weasiness and coffee and a flim? Well,
you want to make sure that you're expelling everything. So there's a purpose in cough and you want
to be expelling that. So make sure the person stays healthy enough to be able to cough, make sure
they stay in a position where it's easy to expel that flim. That's important. There are some
different herbs that can help with that. Lobelia is an herb that helps with the lungs. The first one
that I think of always with the lungs is a medicinal mushroom called corniceps. So corniceps has
very strong lung support. It can even kill cancer that's in the lung, whatever type of cancer it is.
But it's very, it's one of the best things to help heal the lungs.
And then the anti-inflammatory, getbosguelia, curcumin, brobolate, ginger is very good for the lungs.
So, and then, so, and then there's some discrepancy of using, with using glutathyle
and nebulized glutathyle because it's cancer in the lungs. I don't think I would do that.
I just wrote an article. So anyway, as a cancer, it suggests you go to our blog post. I just
did it either this week or late last week and posted it about heartic seed. The dose-dependent
oxidizing effect of different nutrients to help kill cancer. So it explains that cancer
already, cancer cells, because they're in rapid replication, because they're not replicated
really super healthy cells, especially mitochondrial healthy cells. They are more susceptible to
oxidative stress. So I go into detail in the article. So I won't spend a lot of time with that. But
you're at this level of, so when a cell is undergoing oxidative stress, it can kill the cell. So the
oxidative stress, the negative of oxidative stress, it can cause damage to cells. It can cause cancer.
So oxidizing agents, toxins in our environment can be a cause of cancer. It can damage cell
membranes. It can damage mitochondria of cell. It can damage other organelles itself. So that's a bad
thing. But cancer cells, because they're rapidly replicating, they're not replicating a healthy
mitochondria. And it's the mitochondria that is mainly responsible for making glutathione
in a cell, which glutathione is your main cellular antioxidant. So the glutathione is
protecting the cell from oxidative stress. So in a healthy person, in a healthy cell, you could say we
need more components for glutathione, which would be anacetylcystide, which would be taking glutathione
cell, because it's going to help decrease oxidative stress on a healthy cell. So it doesn't get sick. So
it's able to make energy well. That's a mitochondria do. It's able to protect against cancer,
causing oxidative stress. But with a cancer cell, it's already making a lot of excess
reactive oxygen species, because of the nature of the cancer. And you have lethal dose, you could say.
So if you could put it on a bar graph, your lethal dose of oxidative stress, maybe right here,
when a cancer cell is already functioning with a lethal, with their oxidative stress,
reactive oxygen species just below that lethal dose. So if you could tip it over, that's really what
chemotherapy does. Chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent. So it's adding reactive oxygen species to
a cell to basically kill the cancer. While the idea is dose-dependently, there's different nutrients
that have been shown through different studies to actually be maybe antioxidants in a normal dose,
but there actually are oxidative agents higher dose. So you're actually taking a higher dose of this
to kill the cancer, to actually act like a natural chemotherapy. So go to that, I talk about
four different nutrients that work in that article. But the converse of that is true. Do we really want
to use glutathione or etacetal cysteine with people that have cancer? Because then could we not be
keeping cancer alive by, you know, it's really close to that lethal death, that
reactive oxygen species, that lethal dose of reactive oxygen species intracellular. And if we
give it antioxidants, could we be protecting this cancer cell and keeping cancer cells alive?
Well, that's been a debate about natural and standards of care doctors for a long time.
And I have fallen always on the side of, I don't think we should be giving cancer patients
glutathione. But of course, we do testing in our office, so we do cheek saw testing. So we have a
few patients that I do have glutathione that very many. So taking if they oxidants, high-dose
antioxidants for a cancer patient might not be the right thing to do. But if a person didn't have
cancer, and the reason I'm talking about this is because glutathione and etacetal cysteine are so good
for the lungs and cleared out that waste of the lungs. But if they have metastasis in the lungs
that I take, don't want that. There's a lawyer just to get to that point. But I think it's important.